[Music]
marvel's used up their a-list characters
their b-listers and the best available
chris list but before the fox
reinforcements arrive they're reaching
way down deep to dig up one last obscure
hero let's see what's left in here big
bertha
hellcal put her in the maybe pile oh oh
the guy with egyptian magic what's his
name white batman ah
moon knight yeah that's the guy
don't know who moon knight is neither
does he oscar isaac stars as three
personalities fighting for control of
the same hot bod one is steven grant a
modern-day londoner with a vibe of a
dickensian street urchin only the
worthiest would be allowed to pass
through the field of reads isn't he
really gonna do the whole show like that
this is how i talk oh
the other is mark spector a mercenary
with the same tragic past as dewey cox
this is all your fault the wrong kid
died and their third is konchu an
ancient egyptian god who enslaves the
mcu's first jewish superhero so i guess
old habits die hard together they'll
drive his body around like a hot little
clown car in an oscar isaac vehicle
built for one purpose huge acting
choices
[Applause]
now that's a death face right there
that's what you call oscar isaac mwah
you'd think oscar would stay away from
egyptian comic book stuff after the last
time
but this geezer is headed back to giza
for more egypt tropes than a scare
pointing to the hieroglyphics on a
pharaoh sarcophagus as moon knight must
race to find the magic something or
other with the help of his wife leila a
woman who knew all about his superhero
side
but nothing about his ptsd family trauma
or the fact that he killed her dad
classic marvel couple together they'll
team up to defeat jeff arthur harrow
ethan hogg phoning it in as a villain
with the power to be like super judgy
you're a vegan right yeah yeah so am i
no not that judgy thing the other one
the death one i wish you could live to
see the world we make
are you ready for action moonite isn't
because when danger strikes he blacks
out
ugh this reminds me of when four loka
was still legal
instead of fighting watch as the street
level hero gets bogged down by nonsense
worthy of an eternal you'd be surprised
how many intersectional planes of
untethered consciousness exist in a
first half that's just bickering over
who gets to be the main character give
me the bodies give me the body give me
the body mark give me the body you give
me the body and you piss off and a
second half that feels like a janky rush
to make up for lost time your mind is
violently vacillating between sense and
nonsense culminating in a finale that's
marvel's third kaiju ending
and fourth hero meets alternative
version of themselves ending in just
this last year things just got out of
hand and i woke up here and now i'm
surrounded by variants of myself peter
one peter two peter two peter peter
three i mean who says they're running
out of ideas and the genre is eating
itself me i say that
so strap in for a series that may not
have done justice to its amazing cast
may not have done justice to the subject
matter of mental illness and definitely
didn't do justice to one of the coolest
marvel comics characters ever but the
most hardcore mcu fans got what they
were looking for
someone trying to hide by wearing a
plain baseball cap whoa cap confirmed
starring
on the moon knight i am cameron bombs
your uncle tyler burden
elion hubbard the cursed wives club
angry birdman deity at law
ten points to hippoglyph killer croc
you think
you own this body
republicans it belongs
to me
and i'm talking to the man in the mirror
i'm asking him to change his ways
one flew over the conscious nest
oh so this is eternal paradise it's nice
nice
that's a bit boring though isn't it hey
screen junkies before disney plus drops
their next series about how an old
wizard ended up living in a cave spying
on a young boy learn about his more
civilized past and fandom's new video
the evolution of obi-wan kenobi click
the thumbnail on the right to watch now
that ain't no etch-a-sketch this is one
doodle that can't be undead home skillet
amber why you gotta poop the bed
welcome to the next level please help
they won't let me out of this booth i
haven't seen the sun in days